how to raise $50,000 so you can go day
trading this is a question I came in now
if you want to raise money for your
business whatever business idea you have
here's the thing that you need to do
okay when you are approaching potential
investors show me that it works too many
entrepreneurs come and pitch an idea and
it's just an idea and they have no
experience no background and no proof
that it works when I was in the venture
capital business
I got pitched all the time by
entrepreneurs and over 99% of the plans
that came in never went anywhere because
it was just a plan I'm not gonna risk my
money on something that doesn't work
show me that something works and I'll
help you build it up but you got to put
time effort energy dollars into it to
making it work yourself otherwise you're
also gonna get killed in your evaluation
they're gonna take everything from you
everybody has an idea okay and if you
think about people who have money people
who are being approached I kind of
poached all the time
but people will have business ideas how
do you stand out why should I pick you
why should I pick your business from the
thousands of others that come at me
what's gonna stand you out one of the
things is gonna be moment listen you
have something that actually works it's
not just an idea that's gonna be your
first step show me that it works until
you have some momentum until you have
some customer something show me that it
works this is not that hard you have to
get to that point on your own you have
to have something that works on your own
that creates excitement momentum
momentum energy on your own you have to
do that that's on you
stop wasting time looking for an
investor you're gonna burn all your
hours looking for investment dollars and
not actually do anything with your
company go to investors when you have
something that worked and you need money
to grow this whole thing came out of a
question that came in for me on my email
from somebody came named Nevin who wants
to make he wants to raise $50,000 so you
can day trade and he's gonna make $1,000
per day okay
whatever okay so you know what show me
that it works show me that you can make
those kinds of returns because nobody
really makes those kinds of returns okay
if that was guaranteed money then you
could raise capital easy for this but
it's not guaranteed money and you're
probably not going to get there making
these kinds of claims for what my BS
meter so show me for two years and you
can do it on your own and if you have
half of that or quarter of that you have
$5,000 you can start making those kinds
of returns on your own go what do you
need capital for go ahead and do it
yourself
it's gonna explode on you this is great
it's not just following some formula and
it just works
okay people in trying to crack the stock
market for years there's no magic bullet
there's no magic bullet until you show
me that you have one you have one you're
gonna have a lineup of investors so show
me that it works prove it this is for
anything we try to raise capital you
want to start a franchise entrepreneurs
can me say I want to start a franchise
business you wanna start a franchise
show me you can start one location that
works you need a location that can train
people that is highly profitable if
you're one business you're one store is
losing money or is breaking even that's
not a franchise business you have to be
massively profitable because the people
who you sell a franchise to they're not
going to be as successful as you they
don't have as much invested in till
you're the creative visionary you're
bringing on a franchisee they're not
going to be as successful as you see
your store or better be awesome if it's
not if it's not making money you're not
ready to go in franchise if you haven't
proven that you can make these kinds of
returns off of whatever money you have
$5,000 $10,000 if you can't make these
kinds of returns that you're talking
about then you're not ready to bring on
investors cuz nobody's going to give you
the money you're wasting your time so go
out and prove it show me that it works
for any type of raising capital
initiative show me that it works are you
just burning your time prove to yourself
if somebody came and pitch this to you
is
we said hey give me 50 K which might be
their life savings right if somebody
said give me your life savings and I'm
gonna give you this huge return are you
gonna do it are you just gonna hand over
your money for them of course not
right you don't want to make sure that
it works you want security so you gotta
give it to other people especially rich
people who have tons of money because
they're getting approached all the time
by deals when you have something then go
model success I quickly looked up Warren
Buffett's store because to me he's the
guy to model right he's in the
investment business he's the world's
most successful investor and he's not
talking about making these kinds of
returns but how he got started was he
partnered up with the doctor and he
partnered up with that one doctor and
then 10 others and he asked him to give
$10,000 each and he started with that
fun to go out and create his business
but before he did that he worked at one
of the most successful stock agencies in
the world he worked with legendary gurus
who were respected he had a proven track
record so when somebody when he went to
unpick this $10,000 I said yeah we want
to work with you because look at all the
stuff that you have proven so before you
go get investors prove that it works
because they're skeptical because
entrepreneurs are pitching their dreams
to them who have planned out nothing
have no track record no background no
experience I've never done this before
are pitching a dream and that's who
you're going up against and they're
gonna put you in that category and
unless you show them that you you're
different you're standing out you have
momentum and it works believed for those
of you watching you liked this video
give it a thumbs up below it makes you
want to do more for you and let me know
what you think you have a question a
comment leave it below I'll make a video
response I love hearing your questions
come in it's the best part of our week
making these videos helping you guys out
thank you so much and I'll see you soon
you